welcome back to the Rockstar socala is
Haitian now hooray for me because as of
the ending of wakanda forever we now
have a new t'challa in the MCU courtesy
of Nakia and t'challa's seniors love for
one another but what if this is
prize wakandan baby in the MCU because
sometimes you know when you're a white
boy in the jungle surrounded by
beautiful black women you're gonna get
that jungle fever you know what I'm
talking about
all right oh we're going there today oh
so I don't know I think that uh we might
have a little surprise with Bucky in the
future but this is Rogue Fury the show
where we pitch the wildest theories for
the nerdy titles that we love my name is
Mt t'challa's Haitian uncle and going to
Royal complete today is the first person
that KIA told about her secret son is
Jessica Clemens what's going on Jess I
kept that secret because I believe in
child support
Jess supports Her Sisters in any way
possible you know that's that's just a
good a good person right there and also
the inventor of the heart-shaped herb
vape pen it's Whitney van laningham
what's going on oh that's so stupid
yes you can now Vape the heart
heart-shaped herb and you get super
super stoned and you also get real
strong and all your teeth turn to
vibranium teeth and you never have to
you never have to go to the dentist
again exactly down with the dentist
that's the best vape in the world and it
gives you a chill high and finally it's
the secret son of name or the Submariner
equipped with super strength it's the
host of the film philosophers podcast
it's Eddie Villanueva what's going on
what is up guys I am loving the fact
that we are getting more and more
Latinos even the Black Panthers Latino
so I'm excited the future black panthers
Latino so you know what I'm just happy
as a clam I'm wearing my Coco shirt I'm
ready to roll let's go let's go
all right guys it is time for our first
Rogue topic I've missed you guys so much
because it is time to talk about babies
again I know you guys miss a baby
conversation ever since that She-Hulk
conversation but now it is time to talk
about babies once again because Marvel
Studios seems to be plotting for the
next like generation of the MCU I guess
because we got love before love and
thunder now we have uh Toussaint um but
I think that the next character that's
gonna be introduced the next little tiny
child is the child of one
um Bucky Barnes the white wolf in the
MCU
um and the reason why I think this is
because
um we know from the Marvel Comics that
the white wolf was a prominent part of
the wakanan culture he was like this
um this is basically this white dude in
wakanda that like basically got um
adopted by t'chata if I'm not mistaken
and um just take it in and basically
raised as one of his own
um and she was a core part of that
culture and he led the zarase which was
like the
um basically the war dogs of wakanda
um in the MCU
um so I think that what Marvel's setting
up here is for little Tucson t'challa Jr
to have that like relationship and
rivalry with
um uh Bucky's son who he does not know
that he has in wakanda from his time
that he spent there
um getting his brain wiped and like just
chilling on the beach or doing whatever
he was doing herding goats whatever
buckies do in Africa listen if if
there's anyone anyone in the MCU who
would forget he had a child it is
definitely it's Bucky exactly brain wipe
so many times yeah he like he's not just
like a terrible father he didn't just
like leave to get a pack of cigarettes
and never come back he did have his
memory wiped by legitimately forgot
about his child when he went out to get
milk he was like oh [ __ ]
did you he just drinks the milk in the
aisle but just leaves somewhere else
yeah I just leave it just goes back
but no I I think that um especially with
King Dynasty coming up I think that
we're going to experience like a weird
either a Time jump or like people from
different timelines coming together and
I think that we might see
um a grown-up t'challa and a grown-up
white wolf Junior
um with a a child with Bucky and a ver
some random wakanda woman hopefully a uh
a main character from the comics that'd
be really cool but like I I think that
um this is what Marvel is setting up for
maybe a thunderbolt surprise that'd be
really fun what do you guys think I
don't know I I I I like the idea I just
also don't want to dismiss like the
chemistry that was going on between him
and Sarah from Falcon and the Winter
Soldier I mean legit they were crushing
hard and uh I mean hey they'll still
have probably a mixed raise but maybe
he'll take his kid to economy like this
is where I learned to be the better me
kind of thing and uh leave them there or
something I don't know who knows what
will happen but I just I just don't
you're a little baby and you're just
like learn to be a better you kid it
worked for me let it work for you all
right but I I I feel like that would be
that would be an interesting turn to
take especially after like I said after
the events of Falcon and the Winter
Soldier the chemistry that was going on
there and uh I mean can you imagine if
Bucky literally like leaves Sam's sister
high and dry like that like Civil War
Two automatically
Civil War not survive that would be
civil war to 100 you do not [ __ ] with
Sam's sister it's everybody at that
cookout at the end just like going after
bunny it's like how dare you yeah like
we let you help us fix our boat right we
trust you yeah we trusted you so I don't
know I I may need a little bit more
convincing but it would be interesting
if if you were you were talking about
kids and and whatnot in in the MCU we
I'm hoping that t'challa in a nearby
Saga in a nearby iteration of you know
marvel we do get a chance to see you
know t'challa kind of come into The Fray
of becoming the Black Panther
um but who knows like and and honestly
I'm just like don't don't [ __ ] over
Sarah that's all I'm saying just don't
just don't
I mean she was cool as hell like she was
fun she's unreasonable yeah she was
really the only reason why I won Bucky
and Sarah together is so that Bucky and
Sam could be related that's the only
reason why because like I just really
love them I love them together they're
already like brothers they're just like
hey just make it official brother-in-law
obligations uh like a remake of Step
Brothers but this time it's breakfast
exactly and it's just Bucky insane so
whose nuts do you want to see on the
drum set is what I'm asking that's the
important question who's next because
that you know that's gonna happen if
that's the case Jess is already thinking
I'm just saying [ __ ] Catalina wine
mixer they already have the boat it's
perfect
we need to make this happen Marvel
season 2.
brother-in-laws the brother-in-law Wars
so what do you think about this Jess I
think it's think it's fun
I think I like it I like the idea of
just Bucky having a kid but I think it's
kind of
if when they kidnap Bucky
and they brainwashed him seems like the
first thing you would learn in
brainwashing people and making them your
servant for life is to make sure they're
sterile so if they do have to hook up
with someone and honey pot Honey Trap
them or whatever you probably make sure
they can't have a child so he's probably
had a vasectomy I'll go as far as to say
that I'm 100 sure Bucky of all the
people in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
absolutely has a vasectomy he has a
robot arm forced Hydra of vasectomy
that's dark
I'm gonna say he was brainwashed also
Hydra was a bunch of Nazis so it's like
they were already like no I mean no it
100 makes sense if we're looking at
historical evidence I mean eunuchs all
that kind of stuff I mean they were it's
it's I mean not to that extent like but
still to the extent of like keeping
that from moving forward I wouldn't want
them to reproduce I'm sure there's a lot
of there's a lot and a lot that don't
like people have been forced to take the
Super Soldier serum where they're like
yeah we also need to make sure you can't
reproduce or maybe made it so they
couldn't reproduce different bodies
different different situations maybe
they got super semen serum yeah
I I want to believe but then I'm also
like I agree also with Eddie I have been
banking on him and Sarah versus him and
the other dorm Elijah who we saw now
with Michaela Cole and Falcon and black
panther wakanda forever uh I I want him
with Sarah but I also don't want to take
the I like the one child coming out of
wakanda being t'challa t'challa's son
and I don't want to take away from that
but I'm not saying your theory isn't
sound it's fun yeah I would love it I'm
just like realistically this agent would
probably
not nuts no I like that I I've never
really thought about like Hydra taking
the precautions to sterilize because
like I didn't know about that either
that's really smart Jess it is really
smart because like we know from that the
Red Room like did like really messed up
stuff oh yeah
that darkness is there in the MCU
unfortunately when I hear the words Red
Room my uterus just like clenches in a
tiny ball and hates me people
[Music]
it's what I tell them every time I bust
into the room when someone's giving
birth and I say don't touch the tip
don't touch it touch it you leave it as
it is until they can make a decision for
themselves there you go
amen preach it but I I just like really
love like the white wolf from the Marvel
Comics and like I I always find it
interesting that like they gave Bucky
the name white wolf but like never
really did anything with it it's just
like all right yeah they just we just
call you white this is Instagram handle
while he's in Wauconda yeah I also I
like that they call ever Ross a
colonizer but they call Bucky the white
wolf uh it seems kind of bad word seems
like they're picking and choosing
they're like oh this old tiny [ __ ] you
are colonizer this hot ass man
that's also what I call that
my favorite colonizers
but yeah no I I just really love the
dynamic between um t'challa and the
white wolf in the comics and I would
really love to see her Charlie Jr sort
of just follow that and like they have
the opportunity to have like a more
comic book accurate story between those
two rather than like all right here's
t'challa um and then here's random Bucky
white wolf and like we're not gonna
really do anything with white wolf now
because that's Bucky's name yeah I think
it'd be cool if they passed the title on
um in some way or if Bucky took a more
serious role in wakanda and was actually
the white wolf and like we saw how or
even us seeing how we even got the name
white wolf in to begin with because like
he probably did some pretty dope [ __ ]
for wakanda with his cool arm that
sounds like a Disney plus Series right
there what if he just got really high
and ran around tore down the tent that
he was stationed in and then howled at
the Moon the house at the moon and they
were like this is a joke this is just a
bit
that's what I would do if you let me
loose just get real high run over
we'll take the heart-shaped arm do they
just wow yeah
they fall asleep and see Bob Barker in
the ancestral plane
prices
I like that it's like Bob Barker I feel
like it'd be like Bob Hope
um I feel like some sort of Western
white man oh God I would hate I see uh
Gene Wilder oh
[Applause]
but all right guys let's do the voting
time like do you guys think of this idea
of there being a white wolf Junior to be
rogus bogus or August what do you think
Eddie I would say this is August I I
would I would love to see this come to
come to fruition but like I said we got
this great ship with Sarah and and Bucky
and I really want to see right now we're
kind of like you were saying empty we're
kind of in that level of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe where I feel like
they try to stick really close to the
books with the main characters now we're
getting all the kids of these people and
now they're gonna start going balls to
the wall like all crazy easy with story
lines and opportunities to create new
narratives so I feel like this is
definitely something plausible is it
something I would like to see I think I
would want to see that ship first come
to a close at least if that's the
direction but all in all I I feel like
it's it's got some it's got some you
know things going for it it's got some
things going for it's August I'll take
the yogis middle August what do you
think Whitney all right I'm going
um August but leaning rogus because I
also I I really do think it would be
cool to have another little a little
baby guy running around with our little
other baby baby
panther and they're like best friends
it's like the Muppet Babies but in real
life and it's cool
um and they have weapons and it's
awesome uh so that would be great I
really do want to see that I think that
that'd be super cool my only my only
August leaning is just that
um when we prior to Sarah in Falcon
Winter Soldier
he didn't really have much game with the
ladies it's true in my opinion I felt
like Sarah was like a thing that he like
finally came into his own on and was
like oh yeah I think that I do like this
one I am gonna you know participate and
and flirt back but I don't think he had
enough game to have some one night
standing wakanda
I just don't like he's hot enough to get
that done but I don't think he had the
game to get that done but I still want
it to happen we saw in Falcon Winter
Soldier that he was on that date with
that with that girl and it yeah and he's
too old yeah he's just too old he's just
a billion and he's trying to date like
30 year olds right to work that way well
it works with Leonardo DiCaprio
and just saying
I'm King shaming I'm King if you're a
billion years old if you're a billion
years old hear you I'm King shaming I'm
King a billion years old I don't give if
you're 60. a billion years old no that's
wrong in the Cradle what are you doing
robbing the cradle
is wrapping some cradles he's filling
the cradle and also cradle am I right
ladies
if we treat the weird the weird vampire
sibling from Twilight that fought in the
Civil War weird for his thoughts we
should also be treating bucket the same
because they were at the same time and
doing the same [ __ ]
let's treat Bucky and the cast of
Twilight exactly exactly the same that's
what I've been saying
shut up
oh my God I have no idea
what was wrong with her it was too soon
we were ready we weren't ready with the
CGI yet uh I think I'm I'm still a
little stuck on on uh Whitney's whole
Muppets uh wakanda forever kind of thing
here Muppets uh Black Panther I guess we
have to do it like that's the new
Disneyland
with just Muppets that'd be hilarious
and all of that and all of the battle
rhinos are just Muppet rhinos
oh my gosh I would love all the wakanda
if all the um the uh Telecom people were
just like Growers Rover from Sesame
Street they're just all blue and crazy
all right
what do you think Jess well look here
dog
okay all right what you got for me Randy
it's a bogus for me dog
it's a
boats for me dog why you think it's
Focus look here look here dog I thought
it was really fly what you did
I was in it but then I thought about it
and I was like I just don't see it
happen in my I don't see it happening my
dude really I'll take myself out of
Randy Jackson for a minute uh love it
I would love any character get a baby
because that's uh who I am I love the
Baby Looney Tunes I love when you baby
baby five not baby fine
any character I'm obsessed with it I
love it but I'm also like we have so
many babies if we put in another [ __ ]
baby we're gonna like t'challa's not
gonna join the Young Avengers he's six
like he's like five years old the rest
of them are about to go into college
there's another baby we gotta wait on
like because the the new century
Thor baby is also like in preschool I'm
like I'm not good for the white wolves
baby and I do agree with Whitney where
I'm like what game would he have to spit
at anyone in wakanda
I'm sorry but all of those people are so
hot and so from the currency
genuinely know what hip-hop music they
know what Beyonce is yeah he goes what
the [ __ ] is that yeah it just like in
general he's like what's up
yo like they got this dude from World
War II and then put him in like a
futuristic Society that's like above
what modern is yeah I just don't think
he's getting sucked under those
conditions it's true it's true I'd have
a panic attack every second at something
happening someone would deliver a tray
of food floating and I go
like I would be freaking out 24 7. I
don't know why he's still going from the
past to wakanda is just like that's a
jump that's a joke that is a jump and
especially you're going from like uh
East East New York east coast New York
to Africa
seriously
during the racist times to Africa future
Africa this rhino have robotic legs
right
right wow he's like we we had just
invented bayonets
Champion knives to our guns yeah we just
started that we thought it was cool like
we got Bandits you got Wi-Fi what's
going on here what's going on all right
I'll take two August's in a bogus all
right it's it's I I value your opinion
so I will take that with me to the Grave
because I love you guys but up next Jess
has a wonderful Rogue theory for us to
hear and experience because that's just
how Jess rolls but first be sure to
check out newrockstarsmerch.com today
where you can grab our newest latest
Obsession shirts the forever King
inspired by black panther wakanda
forever like all of our latest
suppression shirts this one is limited
edition and won't be available forever
so be sure to check that out along with
all of our other awesome merch options
over at New roccosmerch.com today now it
is time for Jessica Clemens the
wonderful the roguest woman that is in
the world to take away this second topic
Take it Away Jessica
baby I my rogue Theory today that I'm
bringing to this table also is in
regards to Black Panther wakanda forever
I think by the end of phase five wakanda
will be overthrown overrun dead gone
failed
destroyed and I think it's gonna be a
human I think it's gonna be a cumulative
of a bunch of things and here's why we
know that Ryan coogler is an avid comic
book fan and he does really good comic
book fan service with even like
killmonger staying really close to their
storyline even with black uh Black
Panther becoming shuri and becoming
enraged and being really bad like At
first I guess in the movie still staying
on board and we talk about it in our
inside Marvel about how Dr Doom could
have allegedly been the teacher that
stole the plans from um from Riri
Williams to find more vibranium and I
still believe that is to be true and why
I think that is still to be true is
because I think we're going to be
following the Doom War storyline in the
comics where in do more we have
um Dr Doom basically infiltrate wakanda
and I think one big takeaway from
wakanda Forever that we don't think
about uh is that how easy it was for the
talokins to keep getting in
and I think we're and we don't have
really that villain of the MCU anymore
that has that's just like a villain if
that makes sense um when I say that I
think that that's a a really good take
for what I want no more to lead us to so
I think no more and doom will team up
together because we they have in the
comics on the cabal the cabal cabal team
the the team that has the hood and a
bunch of other people that we are
getting in Phase five so I think that
team is gonna start to be formed instead
of the intelligentia we're gonna get
this and that team will start to form
and doom the teacher will start working
with no more so they can go back
underwater to get him into wakanda to
infiltrate and try stealing the
vibranium now that the vibranium is
being built in the Hills or in the
mountains or the forest again and I
think Dr Doom stole those plans is
trying to organize all these things the
smartest man on the planet because he's
trying to get the vibranium from
doomworm he was trying do more he was
trying to get the vibranium so he could
just like it would make him more
powerful it was just like it's like an
extra Stone basically an infinity stone
and he needed it Joe he can make the
entire world a better place and bass had
to let him go through with it and bass
let him do it because ultimately even if
he is a villain he still believes in a
right society and that right Society is
what we kind of need and there always
needs to be a leader in that right
Society so bass let him take the
vibranium to make basically a better
world for all of us and we know that
into Secret Wars this is how it starts
is with wakanda being taken over and
being like the first place for it to
actually start to lead us to Secret Wars
so I think we're getting two phase six
of Secret Wars through wakanda but first
wakanda has to fall and when wakanda
Falls this is the perfect time while
shuri's Black Panther and our leader is
in Baku who won't really see eye to eye
and they're gonna there's gonna be teams
there's gonna be people that are for
them and against them and in different
regions so I think this is the perfect
time to start
interesting but like poor wakanda they
just got their asses
acid I want them to have a nice life I
talk about it in my I I don't really
talk about it but I do bring it up a
little bit in my review how wakanda kind
of feels like new Asgard how they're
like this is the people we are the
string it's the strongest nation in the
world and it is because of vibranium
because that's how they make a lot of
money but it's also because of the
people and we see that in Black Panther
work on it forever when they have to
leave and go to the mountains with the
Jabari tribe it's like you guys still
have a home here we're still with
condens at the end of the day wakanda
forever is the title of this movie so I
think we'll be seeing that again where
it's like yeah wakanda fell but they'll
come back and it'll come back eventually
but I think it's going to fall and it's
going to fall with the hands of no more
doom and anyone else that wants to be on
that really bad team of people yeah I
really like that cool idea man I really
like it I followed that comic series
back in 2010 when it first get debuted
and I really thought the idea of losing
such a unique location to the Marvel
Universe the comic Universe such as
wakanda
it was a pretty big feat and you knew it
was kind of like one of those things
where you know whether if you lost
Superman or you killed Captain America
or things like that it was something on
that scale wakanda is some place that
everybody knows of as a higher Echelon
type of uh of nation
um and to go to the routes within the
Cinematic Universe to start building
those stories and building that you know
plan to ultimately destroy wakanda
entirely
feels as odd as it sounds right because
we are looking to bigger and more
bombastic ways that Marvel is going to
[ __ ] up the MCU internally like within
the world and create this bombastic
story we've already had half of the
universe's population disappear in a
snap what's the next thing we can do
well let's go closer to home and start
removing people who are linchpins who
are you know uh Foundation makers within
the hero teams and start removing their
Foundation as well and I think wakanda
is a great place to start I mean you're
looking at everything that they've done
so far
the the one thing that you can tell when
you if for those who've seen wakanda
forever there was a little bit of
foreshadowing a little bit of
foretelling with some of the scenes like
there's a great scene with uh Namor and
uh and shuri talking about you know the
the greatest leaders or the most broken
people are the greatest leaders and that
right there immediately shouts there's
gonna be some Brokenness in the film but
I feel like that also foreshadows the
rest of this Saga and how they're gonna
go because in order for us to get great
leaders again they have to be the most
broken people and I feel like there's
gonna be a lot of shake-ups like that
and I think wakanda is going to be one
of those ones that they're eyeing to
decimate much like Thor because Thor had
a great Arc you know if you take a look
at from you know one two and then three
with Ragnarok the evolution of his you
know journey is kind of tent pulled
within Ragnarok as everything that he
knows is no longer an existence that
loves him and he loves and all he has is
Loki and the people that is there his
home is gone his father's gone his mom's
gone that movie solidifies he has
nothing left in terms of that place he
can call home his safety his Refuge so
that kind of jump starts him into the
greater role that he has when Infinity
war and War and end game comes
um yeah I feel like this is a really
great thought I realize I really like
this Theory think yeah ah you're welcome
you guys are so smart yeah I'm just over
here like bleep bloop I love it and you
guys are like this is perfect because
like holy [ __ ] I'm like Blown Away by
[ __ ] Justin Eddie right now y'all are
amazing I'm always Blown Away side bit
it has nothing to do with this I was
telling my mom how bad I am at
Impressions but I do a really good R2D2
and she said what the [ __ ] does that
sound like you just go
beep beep bop and I was like no that's
not what I do I scream very loud but it
does it is our Judy to a Scatman or
something or what's what's going on here
okay sorry back to Rogue Theory back to
Rogue Theory and then we'll come back to
Impressions we'll change the the last
one to who has the best Kermit I I do
have a pretty good Jennifer
[Laughter]
but no I really love this idea of um
this of of there being a team where like
Namor is a part of and he's like sort of
working to the sort of like for uh
wakanda's downfall because like I have a
feeling that the MCU is going the dark
rain Direction and like I don't know if
you guys have read the dark brain event
but that's when um Norman Osborne sort
of just like assembles a group of all
the villains and he's like all right
we're gonna sort of like craft the world
in our own image and like I feel like
let's be bad let's be bad but like be
organized and bad and I feel like we we
might see um this is where atuma like we
didn't see a Tuma play a big role in um
wakanda forever but we know that he's a
villain and we know that he's going to
be a villain down the line most likely
um so I think that we'll see a Tuma team
up with Val and like we'll see uh maybe
like I like this idea of the uh the
destruction of wakanda even though it's
terrible like it would be very sad but
like it would much like with Ragnarok
like Eddie said like it would shake
things up and it would like sort of like
progress bmcu and like I think that it
this is the opportunity a really great
opportunity for the MCU to sort of adapt
that uh world of wakanda storyline where
we uh we see t'challa on a completely
different planet they leave like it's a
different planet it's a world it's a
planet of wakanda and I would love if
like wakanda was like all right let's
sort of like do a reverse Asgard leave
the planet because like humanity is just
like we're done with this and like we'll
just go to like um the planet torfo
which is a vibranium Planet already and
let's just make of uh a planet there and
um just like be uh a race of our own
people so like it'd be really cool to
see an entire planet of wakanda I I
can't remember and I there's so many
comic book lines that go along with this
line and I think there was one where
shuri was the Black Panther and a
different one and she like left for a
minute and it got overrun by someone
else again
and it was but that happened so many
times in the comic books where it's like
you leave this throne for a second I'm
gonna come up I'm gonna take it and
finally yeah you just like it could have
been easier if game and Game of Thrones
just work like that it's whoever can sit
on the seat the quickest uh is whoever
gets to the seats
it's like calling shotgun for a car
you're like shut up God
I get to have the kingdoms um but no I
think the situation I think it already
lends itself I think it's gonna it's
it's really hard because it's like
that's a really intensive storyline but
it's like Ryan googler does stick to the
comics pretty well and even if he
doesn't want to a lot of the situation
happening surely becoming the Black
Panther she doesn't take that mantle
someone else takes that like she during
I think it was I think it's during do
more where she she's the Black Panther
because t'challa gets injured and
t'challa deals with the politics and the
business ends of the things so we kind
of have that already with mbaku gonna be
taking the throne and sure he just kind
of doing black panthery things off to
the side and I'm like it just it already
lends itself to that direction of like
the destruction of wakanda but clearly
coming back together and bringing it
back but like we've seen so much of it
we have to destroy it I I don't mean it
in that way of like we have to kill it
but like how are we gonna have so many
wars start here how are we gonna keep
going in
dot hold for motorcycle deal with
everything and then not not destroy it
and come back to it you know it's I
don't know it just feels like storyline
wise it has to and if you think of what
condo wakanda still stands as like one
last gleam gleaming shining example of
Hope in the MCU you know you look at
wakanda and they're still you know
righteous ruling Justice you know you
you have hope for you know a better
future because of all the technology
with everything else going on in the MCU
and not to mention what we've seen
coming down the pipeline with other
films and other villains that are coming
around especially with Kang the
Conqueror coming through I feel like
that being the last kind of Fortress of
you know of of Hope and you know and joy
and whatnot yeah it'll need to fall it
like it just it makes sense I definitely
feel like both Nations might fall
um at some point in in the MCU because
we do we heard that line in what kind of
forever it's like we I don't we don't
want to move telecon again it's like we
don't want to move again and I think
that talocon will eventually have to
move to a different location yeah uh
probably different vibranium meteors say
and they'll in the Atlantic Ocean which
is why they'll probably uh be called
Atlantis because like all right here's
Atlantis blah blah I gotta know how big
it is because like we got like a hint
sorry to like go on a tangent but like
we got like a like a a brief tiny
glimpse of how big is but like because
that's just that's just the capital city
yeah and it's it stuck with me so hard
like it like it like hit me to my core
and I like got chills in the theater
when he was like we have as many like
members of our army as you have Blades
of grass in the field and I was just
like oh [ __ ] that's so [ __ ] scary to
think about because the ocean is so big
and it's already so vast and dark and
scary and we already have no idea half
of what the [ __ ] is out there and now
there's mer people and they could be
everywhere ah I'm so sorry that I went
on this tangent but like no no like it's
true I also I'm I'm afraid of talocon I
think it is it's a terrifying concept
and I feel like you know that is what's
going to give Val her Credence to like
attack attack wakanda because like you
know these are you people are afraid of
things that they don't understand and
like we are if we're human beings and
we're surrounded by water like wherever
you are you're gonna be surrounded by
water like water makes up like 70 of the
planet or whatever I forget the
statistic
um I ask it every time someone said 79
someone said 89 I said 96 I don't think
that's correct at all right it's 100 I
would take yours above anything else
because that's just how scary it is yeah
it's terrifying also it's one thing
until you put chlorine in that [ __ ]
water then he can't swim in it
so that's how I plan on killing them in
a pool yeah you have these people that
like live underwater and can survive
under the crazy pressures of water that
in itself is like oh my God like if we
war with these people that can like
survive in the depths of water we're
going to lose because like these guys
are durable and like could probably take
a bullet dude you know those you know
those blob fishes where like when they
bring them to the surface they look
really ugly but underneath all the
depths to pressure their normal bro
that's like to hollow cons times 10
billion thousand like holy [ __ ] like
when you take them well and if you think
about it too we only have seen as as
Whitney mentioned earlier talukan is
only the capital city which means yeah
there may be cities just about in every
other ocean major ocean out there that
all work or worship
you know
that was gonna be my rogue Theory today
and then they said no Jessica
um go on
and then they said Brandon looked me in
the eyes he slapped my face and he
called me a [ __ ] there you go
Brandon's a nice boy
that was nice you guys think
I feel though like we I I feel like if
anything happens to talukan that they're
just going to re kind of populate to the
another major city and make that their
capital city I feel like talukan is big
but I feel like there's a bigger city
out there that they have they just much
like like here in California you know
you you hear about LA or San Francisco
but Sacramento is the capital Sacramento
ain't [ __ ] it's not that big but La is
huge you heard it here for a Sacramento
like in terms of size
my apologies to all of our listeners in
Sacramento I'm in Sacramento so he knows
not what he means I'm just kidding but
the idea that the size of it doesn't
dictate the the title of it doesn't
dictate the size just because it's the
capital city doesn't mean it's their
largest city which means there's
probably a city that's primarily all
about their military and like their
armies and their soldiers there's
probably cities out there that are vast
and huge that will hopefully get to
visit soon because I feel like as even
though we got a great chance to view the
city and and see the scope of it I
really do feel like there's something
bigger out there
you're saying is that Tyler
can't grow or not exactly
it happens sometimes my
suck to sucker
I show the growth baby
girl all right
I earned it and I'm gonna show it
okay sorry go on but all right guys what
do you guys think of this theory of a
condo eventually being destroyed is it
rogus bogus or August what do you think
Eddie I think it's bogus I mean I think
it's rogus sorry not bogus yeah
you gave like a really impassioned
monologue that like changed the way I
felt and now you're like actually I'm
like and on top of all that I don't
believe it no no
twists exactly I think it's rocus I
definitely think it's something that is
on the horizon in fact I honestly feel
like that is the direction they're gonna
go they have to do something like this
in order to really solidify the depths
of the the the situations that they're
going to be going into in this next Saga
and it's it's only a matter of time you
you know because it's it's something
that as they're building up these new
villains and they're going to be
revealing all these new aspects of what
Marvel is wanting to do further into the
MCU
losing wakanda as a physical nation is
probably top priority on that list to
start creating that feeling of of you
know hopelessness and so forth so I
think it's rogus not bogus okay no I
remember what you said earlier so you
know what that's the one I'm gonna hold
in my heart all right uh Whitney what do
you think it's rogus dude this is very
very [ __ ] interesting and I think
that you're right I I just think that
it's the next logical place for us to go
especially considering that it is like
it is like a real symbol of Hope for the
world and for wakanda themselves and
like yeah I can't say anything cool that
you guys haven't already said
yeah I'm I'm also going to say
um rogus because if there's one thing we
know throughout history is that um
colonizers be colonizing and uh they
they they
want that those resources so badly they
do it will come to your land and they
will listen to The Red Hot Chili Peppers
exactly they will do that to you don't
don't sleep with one eye let's just say
it Elaine from Seinfeld is coming Elaine
from Seinfeld exactly Elaine from
sideboard is coming in with him no
rhythm having asses yeah
just a land
exactly it's like but yes no I I think
that um it's only a matter of time
before like wakanda gets destroyed and
like I think it makes sense considering
like we the the phrase wakanda forever
because like
well even if wakanda is destroyed it's
sort of like Asgard it's like wakanda is
a people not a place so it's just like
it doesn't matter where we go and like
now that we know there's there's more
vibranium on the planet we can just go
wherever we just be like all right dude
wakanda we'll just go on this vibranium
now uh maybe the one in Antarctica who
knows um but yes no I like this it's
super rogus as always you are the Rogue
Queen which makes Jessica a rogue winner
for today
yes
now uh it's time for our Rogue question
you guys ready for this one because now
that black panther wakanda forever has
officially come out we can officially
declare phase four over in the MCU not
counting the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special which is going to be
amazing and it's but that is like more
of a phase for epilogue but looking back
on any phase 4 movie or series what
would be the roguest change that you
would make to one of these projects I'm
gonna go first because I've said this
time and time again I'm gonna hold the
mic for this
um are you gonna say Ryan Gosling white
panther again black panther because
I'm on that soapbox every morning in our
meetings but not here not here not here
I'm saving I'm saving that one for
tomorrow morning Friday TGIF uh bring
back my white panther
Ryan Gosford
make this panther white again so I I
um long story want to change everything
about Black Widow short story
um I just want Taskmaster to get Justice
and one of my God one little thing I
wanted that never happened and this is
not even Rogue this is me being mad one
thing that didn't happen that should
have happened is you made two jokes
making fun of Scarlett Johansson's Black
Widow uh falling into a position that's
like yeah you make two jokes and then
when she first meets Taskmaster
Taskmaster doesn't do it well that that
character is a copycat make it copy
people it was I would have given I would
have given a little leeway I would have
given you guys at least one point but
you guys didn't and now Taskmaster have
a zero and I so long story uh the Black
Widow short story just Taskmaster fix
them okay all right no I I would 100
agree Taskmaster wasn't the best in my
opinion not the best uh job that they've
done but there's plenty of room for
growth there so like exactly who knows
honestly I might they might hit it in
Thunderbolts I still have a and I think
it's only because I love Taskmaster so
much that's the only reason why I'm like
so
irritated about it it hit a heart
history it's all good what do you guys
got I think one of the things I would
change
I would change so in shanxi
I would change
the reveal of the ant played by Michelle
Yao
the I would have them change at the end
credit scene that she's actually Aletta
orgord from Guardians of the Galaxy 2
because I don't know if you guys
remember Michelle Yao is in Guardians of
the Galaxy 2 and she just like changes
like the at the end we see her in her
whole form changes her clothes and then
she gets into a ship she goes okay now
time to get down in dirt and she leaves
like I would I would have liked to see
that kind of connection just because I
mean you got that redundancy of her
character not that I'm you know
complaining that Michelle Yao is in two
different places in the MCU but I would
have liked to make that connection okay
okay I like that I like that a lot
that's still that's still a big question
there yeah what do you got Whitney all
right so here's what I would change
instead of She-Hulk being a fourth wall
breaking show about dating it would
instead be Hawkeye and Haley Steinfeld
would break the fourth wall come out of
the TV and bmt's girlfriend
yeah wait a minute
okay
um obviously I would love for that blue
Skidoo scenario to happen to be that
would be amazing
um but yeah I don't know
if I can choose that without feeling
favorites I that's what I want to choose
but I'm going to choose which is also
changed
which I also changed to be more I just
have the same one now so get over here
exactly there you go oh so I have to
have to give it to Eddie because that's
a really great idea
by default
um I can't choose the one that I really
wanted oh no um this is it's a really
great idea because I really want them to
explain why the the Michelle Yao is uh
these two characters and like like are
they variants because like we do see
that like talo is basically Another
Universe so like what is the answer to
that there yeah so um yeah it'd be
really dope with that if they did that
but I think I would change what would I
change
um
I would make
that would make Toby Maguire and Andrew
Garfield Mysterio projections
just Patrol everybody
do it let's go let's do it the ultimate
Cinema troll Mysterio just make the
intro for the Toby McGuire fake so that
everyone just like I don't know just
gets their hopes up and cries the idea
of Mysterio programming
Garfield to tell his friends that he
loves it exactly it's like I didn't
really love you with cereal being like
you know what
there you go but no I love all these
Rogue answers you guys are amazing but
thank you guys for joining me on this
episode of Rogue Theory as always please
follow Jessica Clemens Whitney van
landingham and Eddie Villanueva on all
of their social media platforms they're
amazing people you can support our
Channel by checking out all of our
awesome merch over at New
rockstarsmerch.com and if you got
thoughts on some of our Rogue theories
you can share them on our Discord just
make sure you're over 18. you can click
the link in the description to join the
Discord today you can follow me at
masterton on Twitter if you want to see
me tweet some weird shits you can follow
new rockstars on all social platforms
and be sure to subscribe to new
rockstars here on YouTube we love you
guys so much thank you guys for spending
time with us and we'll see you guys next
time goodbye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]